when I am president on day one instead
of fighting Texas I will work hand inand
with Governor Abbott and other border
states to stop The Invasion seal the
border and rapidly begin the largest
domestic deportation operation in
history those Biden has led in should
not get comfortable because they will be
going home now the big news here is that
we actually have it's the number is much
bigger than this but there is a report
25 States Republican governors of 25
States have signed a letter back in
Texas now the number is actually larger
than this by now but things are changing
so rapidly it's hard to know exactly how
many states have already joined in and
needless to
say look guys I I can't believe this is
the headline we're writing obviously
everyone's trying to be a little light
on how they describe this mediaite is
just saying Trump calls on state to
deploy National Guard as the state
clashes with the federal government